you can see the grid appearing at the
same time we have more options we have
also curvy roads not just a straight one
so you can really just do pretty much
the kind of shapes and look of the
traffic Network as you want you can also
make bridges for example over over the
river here and it will automatically
create create the bridge there we have
six different zones in in general for
the for the game but now first you have
only the lowest low density residential
commercial and then industrial zones
with the order field tool it's really
simple to just pick one part and
basically just by clicking fill fill an
area the brush tool which is more handy
with the curvy roads so you can just
paint where you want this is the
commercial low-density commercial zone
as well as industry we can use now for
example to mark a tool which is to cover
huge areas at once then with the d zone
you can take part away the parts that
you didn't like so basically what we
have here is you can see the different
kind of zone demands so now for example
when you start building the city there's
a high demand for a residential zone and
then after people start to move in as
you can see over over on the residential
side we have we have people moving in
and now these houses are starting to go
up starting to ask for services so you
should set up the electricity and water
systems which are the really the basic
systems let's be environmentally
friendly and set up what is coming is
wind turbines so we have those now there
and you can see them starting to work so
they people start complete stop
complaining about the missing missing
power and with power lines if you have
this kind of different grades which are
not actually connected yet because the
houses do work as kind of power power
lines as well
but then it's super quick to just join
those different areas with the power
it's a it's a dynamic dynamic water
system so you can actually see from the
this can't interview mode that the water
is going to a certain way so after
placing the water pumping station
upstream I definitely want to put the
drain pipe to downstream because we
don't want the people to drink basically
poop water right so that would be mean
so then by connecting connecting these
together to the to the city we offer
them working water so now we're still in
the starting map tile the two kilometers
times two kilometers and over here now
you can see a lot of different things we
have for example medical clinics for the
people to seek health care there's
garbage disposal to make sure the city
stays clean Police Department fire
department different kind of education
options public transportation and then
we have decoration tool this is one of
the really cool things that of course
you want to kind of tend to your CDM
make it pretty and make sure that
citizens love it so what we can do is we
can place different kind of parks for
people to enjoy
these parks you can actually make
yourself so there's a modding tools that
we're working on so you can actually
take all of the props that we have in
the game and recreate or create
different kind of parks save them and
they will actually appear in in the menu
so that you can place the same park that
you have created over and over again you
can do that in game as well so just by
building some pathways you can place a
couple of trees next to it sorry there's
still a couple of placeholder
placeholder icons there but this is
basically to kind of cover those areas
in the city that kind of go between the
buildings that you they're kind of like
sad looking places and you don't want to
leave them like that so you can just
place trees there and make people happy
you can see actually people actually
come into the park to enjoy all of these
citizens are individuals so you can
actually go and be like a stalker and go
check mr. Earl Murray and you know check
where he actually lives you can really
follow him close by when he's walking
around go check where he lives you know
okay over here and then also see the
status of his his house so all of these
citizens are unique they they either
move into the city they can be born in
the city and unfortunately they will
also move on either by moving out or
then by dying in the city so you also
have to make sure that you have
cemeteries placed in so kind of going
for realism there but of course in these
kind of games realism is kind of the
inspiration we take from but we also
want to keep it you know game so it it
should be also fun
so yeah this is this is where we are at
this point and we're looking to release
this game late q1 next year
[Music]